pour rendre hommage à évidemment aux
combattants et on s'est demandé si nos
chroniqueurs pour en faire autant on a
pris donc au hasard totalement au hasard
francesca et gilles verdez qui vont
devoir vous convaincre d'être l'année
prochaine
oui en faisant un discours politique
mais vous allez voir comme on est apte
ou pas mon poste
forcément il va se passer deux trois
choses on le retrouve en direct vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
leur gras elle est belle doit me
convaincre de me choisir pour rester la
saison prochaine
ça commence mal alors je vous demande
j'ai brûlé le drapeau vous représentez
le charisme la veille
la collection le charme a pas mal pas
mal parce que
ouais
votez pour moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors le soir
non mais on est arrivé vous aimez c'est
la pluie benoît non plus mais
honnêtement quand à la nuitée sur marie
gilles meystre aussi sexy va lancer des
salles deux ambiances bigarrées ses
cheveux c'est la grande question
non parce que je crois que sont vraiment
ses cheveux voilà comme j'ai remis à la
différence de vos pectoraux emea sens
des vraies va les toucher
on retrouve tout de suite la détention
de gilles verdez c'est parti
[Musique]
mes chers compatriotes je suis
aujourd'hui opposée à francesca je fais
beaucoup d'entre vous est-il que ce
n'est pas un scoop
et bien ils ont raison vous n'avez pas
de choix à faire je suis la seule option
valable je suis aujourd'hui je me jette
à l'eau plutôt si l'eau se jette sur moi
c'est parce que j'ai le sens du
sacrifice
je serai présent avec vous chers
compatriotes pour accrocher toutes les
tempêtes
celle qui est là vient du ciel et pour
l'autre eux c'est celle qui vient du
site de castaldi parle heureusement
elles sont rares alors mes chers
compatriotes fait pour
[Applaudissements]
saisie lorsque c'est à dire nous sommes
en budget restreint donc népal au chaud
alors très vite oui bon kim jin jing
pour l'engager j -louis allait saigner
les deux ouais bon polar déni de lune
parce qu'elle est belle notre pitié qua
non
[Applaudissements]
j'aime les deux villes j'ai très bien la
chaîne bravo francesca mais gilles sans
aucun doute les deux les deux oui et
francesca me voilà ça fait à peu près
tout le monde a gagné
[Applaudissements]